i have a theory on joshua which is that
um i think that when you're that rich
that much of a superstar and you have
that many other options it's hard to
fight a russian dude who's that who's
that who wants i found he was he could
have been more aggressive like he just
looks more tentative i don't know if
it's money i think i think for joshua
sometimes he just doesn't show up and
like
he was supposed to win he was a huge
favorite so i think he over like he has
a problem with overlooking guys he did
the same thing with andy ruiz yes right
and then i bet you he would beat usyk if
they fought again do you think he just
overlooks do you think but or maybe he's
not he's a boxer right uh he's not as
skilled as zeus yeah he's more skilled
than andy ruiz yeah and i think he's
more skilled than deonte walder not as
skilled as tyson fury right but i think
the problem is is that was a mandatory
and now he [ __ ] lost so it [ __ ]
everything up but i think you know he's
looking at fury and wilder and when
those don't happen it's such a letdown
but you're still fighting at the highest
level you have to defend all these belts
yeah and who says no [ __ ] people man
you got to get
out of but maybe not tyson he's right
there he more skill-wise better than all
of them is he's too small for uh
uh tyson fury
usyk um i don't know i think i i don't
think he's to finish any of them but as
far as slick boxer he's better than all
of them yeah tyson's [ __ ] slick so
it's tough but yeah he's the one who had
trouble i do think uzik does i think he
gives uh wild talent while they're a big
problem we'll see because wilder's with
the new camp
apparently he's working his job a lot
but also if wilder you know if usyk
lands those shots and then wilder slams
one it's it came over correct
he does stand here like this
and while they're land and they land
there's nothing in there and they say
nobody hits harbor no no no never i mean
top [ __ ] three of all times you've
got ours like he yeah that's god gift
god gift yes he hits you
but and his fundamentals aren't right
his foot comes off the ground yeah it's
loopy but it's just
i've seen i've watched his highlights
this is what they say
and he has a new camera his new camp is
working on his [ __ ] jab his piston
jab they're like why are you not using
you got that crazy right use your jab so
it's going to be really interesting when
he fights tyson fury to see if that jab
can get it's tough to figure that out
when you're fighting tyson fury it's
tough to catch him with that why is that
at that level to throw that in like oh
now you're gonna set the right hand up
with jabs and you've grown up your
entire life not doing that yeah and
here's tyson fury the best boxer who's
wilder's issues can be he can't fight
off his back foot yeah and fury knows
that and completely dominating that so
he's going to probably crowd him
pressure him you know force him to fight
his back foot so there's not like
there's not enough days in the year for
him to try to figure out how to fight
off your backflip yeah now i still have
give him a really good chance of winning
though
uh wilder wilder yes because of that
right touch of sleep yeah and i don't
know and with fury you don't know i
don't know if i'm buying the covet thing
to push the fight i don't the the mental
game like for him it's all mental right
he's better than everybody yeah but if
you don't come mentally sharp he loses
so we'll see
that's right it's a great fight though